did you love doing second city
i did i did i didn't uh boy you know it
seems like the whole career has been one
really happy accident and that really
was i did no intention to work there i'd
done some improv in chicago
i went to college at northwestern yes i
done
improv scene in chicago but you saw like
pure improv no nothing written just
pure hour-long improvs and a friend of
mine
was the box office manager ann libra
lovely lovely friend of mine who was
working the box office manager
i had no money i mean not a dime i was
sleeping on a friend's floor
and she said hey do you want to just
answer the phones here at the box office
just to give you any money at all and i
said okay
and so i answered the phones and and
because i was working there i could take
improv classes for free
with you know these other people my my
same year people were people like you
know
steve carell and and amy sedaris yeah
and we all got to be friends and and i
i it's kind of this habitat for broken
toys like people who are all a little
damaged who have a safe place to go like
all show businesses really
but it was this wonderful little uh
oasis in
chicago when i didn't have any money or
anything i could always go in there and
mooch a beer
or steal a basket of cheese so i didn't
you know have to starve that night
and and every night you could go up and
try to make something as the old saying
goes something wonderful right away by
improvising
and um and through that i learned how to
i learned scene structure by
turning the improvs into written
sketches and and i made
you know friends like amy and paul
danello friends for the rest of my life
my my greatest friends and my oldest
friends are from there and i couldn't
have loved it more
you've done comedy through second city
and a different variety of comedy
through colbert report and a comedy
through your show when
do you know it's okay
and appropriate to be funny ooh wow that
that that question at the end just whew
came in and just
caught me by surprise there at the end
that's not one i expected that's the
drew barrymore
touch um
comedy is always appropriate unless
you're making light of someone else's
tragedy because there's something about
that i think that is sacred to that
person
and you don't want to diminish their
experience so
uh death is not a subject um
or or a tragedy a death or a mortality
or a tragedy in your life
is not a subject for comedy but other
people's
response to it might like perhaps
someone who
is not taking it seriously enough and
not perhaps leading people toward the
answer
toward a tragedy in our country is a
source because then you're talking about
hypocrisy
or a failure of leadership or something
you're not talking about the tragedy
itself so
often i like to say that you know
tragedy is the hub of the wheel
you know the where the spokes are
meeting and you can talk about
where the spokes go out here how it
affects our lives
and that's appropriate but um the actual
the source
the the hot spot of the tragedy itself i
think it's the best thing to do to
to leave that alone because that's not
respectful to the people who are
actually living that experience
you know how and when
and where to lead us into the
light and humor and where to be sacred
are we still talking about chris evans
[Applause]
because
because you know that's you know when to
share and when not to share
is what we learned about that
and and light and darkness because i
believe it was a black and white
photographer
very good the wiener
um that's why i love you
thank you thank you for gracing
our show with your presence i don't
think there are pom-poms
large enough on this globe that i hold
and do this for you thank you